تشيل معطيات الميدانيه ان الرد الروسيه
على الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد قد بدا
بالفعل وان الوحدات الاوكرانيه منخرطه
حاليا في عمليات دفاعيه وهجوميه على طول
خط التماس بين الجيشين بحسب نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني حان مليار كفافه الرد
الروسي في دانيات تبدو واضحه في اتجاه
محور افديافكا استهدفت القوات الروسيه
بقصف مدفعي مكثف مواقع للجيش الاوكراني
ونفذ سلاح الجو غارات على افدي افكا
ونوفوباخ متافقه وفي اتجاه محور ماريانكا
في دانيت قصف الجيش الروسي عددا من نقاط
تتمركز فيها القوات الاوكرانيه التي تمكنت
من احراز تقدم ميداني بنحو كيلومتر واحد
في مقاطعه اجليدار رغم استمرار الاستهداف
الروسي
ايضا تعرضتان لقصف روسي بحسب ما افادت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ونبقى في الجبهه الجنوبيه حيث قالت
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في اوديسا ان
الدفاعات الجويه تعاملت مع هجوم جوي
بمسيارات مفخخه وصواريخ كروز الوضع عند
الجبهه الشرقيه لا يختلف كثيرا اكثر من
منطقه في بخموت تعرضت لقصف مدفعي ترافق
ايضا مع غارات لمقاتلات روسيه وتظهر صور
من محور بخموت نشرها الجيش الاوكراني ان
الطرفين يخوضان قتالا مباشرا
وعلى وقع توسيع رقعه الرد الروسي على
الهجمات الاوكرانيه المضاده رحب الامين
العام للنيتو يانبرغ بقرار بعض من دول
الحلف تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على
استخدام مقاتلات لكنه قال ان من المبكر
اتخاذ قرار بشان تسليم الطائرات واعتبر ان
المكاسب الاوكرانيه على الارض ستلعب لصالح
كييف عند الوصول الى مرحله المفاوضات
المحتمله لانهاء الحرب
[موسيقى]